freeway Rick Ross in the building yes we
were just talking about the Grammys last
night in the Red Hot Chili Peppers
showing up and everything but you know
you know welcome my friend yeah glad to
be back
good to see man Oh friends yeah you said
you're in town doing something you do
know you came in for a reason you're
doing some other show yeah yeah yeah no
I'm here because my new book came out
I'll be seeing Gary Vee today meeting
with him I think that his philosophy is
is is so much like mine you know when I
hear him speak I was like wow this guy
says everything that I think you know
yeah do you think you get enough respect
as a businessman because you I mean your
story is amazing I think most people
know it by now but you made somewhere in
the neighborhood of 900 million dollars
in the drug trade years ago to the point
where it actually like with inflation
and everything looks more like 2.5
billion my 119 now I think people
respect my business mind yeah I don't
think they look at you like an
entrepreneur no they don't they don't
and and and I'm definitely that because
I believe that everything that has
happened to me in my life has been
behind my entrepreneurship you know from
going to prison you know I tell people
that you can't just walk up to a federal
prison and not going to do and say you
want to go in you know you like you see
like El Chapo in like Forbes you know as
a guy who's like they're looking at him
like he's a businessman right it's all
the timing to like now now I feel like
the the the giant drug dealers are
getting a TV series made of them and
they're being made kind of into heroes
enormous enormous TV shows I mean
Escobar has like four series going on
Netflix right now right from people
planning and so forth so it's well you
know I mean the world has a fascination
with drug dealers I mean we have to come
to grips with that most people don't
want to admit it but I mean that's the
way it is you know
we love drug dealers I love drug dealers
before I was one you know right so when
I saw the movie Super Fly I was like oh
my god
that's who I want to be like or the ass
is not the right guy we as a country you
know we have I mean you walk in
anybody's house they got a picture
Scarface you know well they find them in
a lot of the cartels when they raid
those like the real crowd realized in
Mexico they find Scarface posters like
those the real guys love Al Pacino and
everybody loves the first 2/3 nobody
likes the end nobody nobody pays any
attention to the end of the drug unit
movies they all like the first you all
right you know - cause your sales you
know - yeah dimension lifestyle oh it
goes it's dramatic I mean you go from
from high to low real fast yeah you know
they be talking about it no songs from
from zero to 60 real fast will you go
real fast
from sleeping and especially just cuz
you're you're so hot like you're
sleeping the greatest bed ever you got
women everywhere it's like when you're
broke and then you go to jail it's
probably not that different but being a
billionaire they don't really put broke
people in jail they don't I mean I mean
not super broke if it's crazy I mean the
guys who go to jail for having money or
is one thing and then you know if you go
out and commit a violent crime and then
you'll go to jail if if you broke what
I'm saying like in the drug business
they don't they don't keep the boat
broke drug dealers in jail they just
don't I mean they take the broke drug
dealers and they try to get them to flip
over on the ones that are actually
making money right absolutely that's the
whole deal that's the whole deal so when
you're Rick Ross you go to jail how do
people treat you when you walk in are
they nice to you are they not are there
other guys were they not kind to you
because I know I don't think I would do
very well in that scenario I have a nice
heinie the only thing is bubble butts
walking oh my god yeah [ __ ] yeah you
know I'm fortunate to be Who I am
and I do get quite a bit of respect even
the guards
you know the guards who like me they
really like me and then the ones who
don't they hate me but the most of the
inmates for the most part I was able to
literally cross lines that they don't
allow a lot of people to cross when they
in prison was that because you you kind
of were wholesaling to the gang so like
you kind of knew guys from both sides I
did I did but even even even past that
even with the with the Hispanic gangs
and white gangs they even gave me a bit
of a leeway that they don't give other
black guys and imprison like what
sitting at certain tables you know going
over and in a certain area to jail jail
is very segregated you know they have
their territories you know the Crips
that have the area the Bloods had a
area'd in the Mexican Mafia had an area
the white supremacists have the area so
it's very segregated and if you sit on
one of those areas or one of those
tables in a chow hall you're in
violation if you turn no gentrification
in jail no they're not politically
correct at all yeah what happens if
you're sitting if you walk in and you're
like it the Mexican Mafia stable of the
white supremacist table just having a
snack yeah you could start a war come up
and say something to you you know are
you at our table you ain't posed to be
on this table and they're not supposed
to do something nothing tell you because
that could start a race war with with
with you know with the whole with the
whole thing because it's kind of like
uncorrect for white supremacists to do
something to a black in jail a black is
not supposed to do nothing with to a
white supremacist or Mexican unless they
go and get permission from from the game
cuz it's gonna be a problem to start
something don't be some huge so could
you would you be able to say what
gentleman I was sitting here first for
30 years they gave you a certain amount
of leeway yeah yeah yeah I got a little
leeway you know that they didn't give a
lot of black guys you know and I
respected it and I tried to use it the
right way and never to uh to violate
that privilege that I understood that I
was getting how do you when you're in
you're in jail how do you line up guys
who are gonna look out for you like I
mean I know how I'd probably expect it
to do it would be an unpleasant way
clean the socks of a larger man so yeah
how do you line up with guys who are
gonna like look out for you what you
know for me yeah it's totally different
from you this you're not from the street
so you know known about this I know
people look at me and they do think I'm
Street but I'm really not you know Rick
you may not know this but Jim Norton was
in a gang when he was young yeah when I
was 12 or 13 was the name of the gang
the Lord's it's really hard to line up
people that's going to be loyal to you
if you're not really from where they
from because more than likely they're
gonna be scheming on you you know it's a
lot of that work where I mean I see
young guys coming in all the time and
they scared they don't know what to do
and then they go running to certain
people and these people are gonna take
advantage of them so you have to be
really careful about who you align
yourself with because once you align
yourself to a gang now you literally
take an oath to uphold whatever they
stand for so you have to be really
careful about who you aligning yourself
with but you know what guys you know
like they say when she went to prison uh
he went in bought all the guys TV sets
and he bribed them yeah I mean pretty
much yeah yeah I feel like you had to
bribe him or was no no no no no my my
status was totally I had my credit
coming from the streets already right so
so when I got to prison there was guys
already in prison that that I had ran
with on the street I looked out for you
know who I'd help get money so
automatically when I came they they
cater to them so they're gonna protect
you when Suge Knight goes in and he buys
everybody TV sets
how much loyalty does that buy is that
the type of thing where he's good now it
forever if going to [ __ ] up it could be
because you know once you at that time
you know shook head you
he had one of the biggest record labels
ever I've got a fastest growing
independent label ever so he could
continually
buy TV sets put money on people's books
of contrary so literally you're you're
buying loyalty as long as you keep
feeding us you know because that's the
other thing like you can't just go in
buy a TV set and then never buy anything
else again a little bit once they see
okay this is the guy that there's buying
his body's way no question but but at
the same time I mean winning the the
favor who cares how you get it you just
want it yeah as long as you're in there
for a little bit of time if you're doing
life it's like okay I might need to get
some respect just play guilty to twenty
five years so now he's probably gonna
have to do the same thing over again
that he did when he doesn't have as much
death row money coming in exact now yeah
I'm sure people don't want yeah yeah you
know he killed uh they found him guilty
of killing Terry Carter so you know he's
one of the founders of blood so it's not
good he has a lot of issues wait Terry
Carter's not the guy he ran over that's
the guy who ran over yeah exactly that
guy was that's Terry Carter yeah I had
no idea who he wasn't he just said that
he's one of the founders of the Bloods
that's not good it was three guys a big
pudding tarakudo and Terry Carter all
three of them are dead now and two of
them you know God killed behind death
row you know um putting who who was
really the the muscle guy was shot in
the back while he was with death row he
later died in common lesson all had you
met any of those guys I know all of them
yeah yeah I knew all of them
what do you think your advantage was in
the drug game I was able to go to cert
high said you know so many other people
weren't able I mean it's really the same
way I'm doing everything right now you
know I always look for the best people I
can find I try to align myself with
great people you know in the drug
business I would look for a guy who was
down on his luck but was a great guy you
know they got people walking the street
they're the great people but
got that break that they need or nobody
has discovered them or they haven't
learned which button to turn or which
doorknob to open or which phone call to
pick up to to get them to that next
level and what I tried to do is I tried
to align myself with with those people
who uh who could get me to that next
level you know I'm always looking for
somebody who was better than me who's
brighter than me to surround myself
around and and you know that's the way I
do I do life with everything that I do
you know I'm always looking for people
that just going to be able to help me
get to the next level when I'm always
trying to find somebody smarter than I
am
you were all so quiet right like I mean
that you know in a way that that you
weren't showy there wasn't this thing a
lot of people end up on on magazine
covers and things like that before they
go to jail or anything people just kind
of know I don't think anybody outside of
you know your candice streets knew
anything about who you were until after
all this story had been told yeah yeah
yeah well I tried to play it low-key
because you weren't wearing the fur to
the fight right do you think Nicky
Barnes made a judgement error when he
did the Sunday Times as Luke I mean he
got famous though you mean everything
but you're making all this money and
you're so successful what you're doing
and you see other people getting credit
for it isn't that doesn't it ever creep
up on you that you're like well I want
that credit I want people to know what
you going to the game for you know when
I went into the drug business I was
looking for a stepping stone you know I
I didn't want to be a career drug dealer
that was never my plan my plan was I was
gonna get in yeah make enough money to
paint my car and give me some rims and I
was gonna be out giving nine hundred
million dollar car yeah what point do
you realize okay this is not just
something I'm gonna jump in and jump out
of well you know you start off making
twenty dollars a week right and then you
start making five hundred hours a day
and then you're like whoa I might be on
to something here and there next thing
you know you're making a hundred
thousand a week and I'm really on to
someone will go ahead and make me a nice
nest egg and and then walk away but
it's tough man I to stop selling drugs
is tougher than to the start know to
stop using stop selling because listen
when you use people will tell you a you
know you effing up but when you sell and
everybody gonna be going yeah keep going
when we realize that like how do you
realize I should say that wholesale is
the way to go and what do you do with
that amount like that just the sheer
amount of drugs that you had to
transport cuz you see guys trying to
figure out like just just a pocketful
people get busted for yeah the amount
that you're going
[Laughter]
my buddy showed it to me it was so small
I was like man the police had never
catch me with this right and I was
always correct yeah I would just start
it and yeah then you have a roomful of
it you just throw it in the trunk of a
car in the back of a van I mean if if
you drive it right and and then you know
what we would have is we would have what
we would call decoy cars yeah you know
if we move in in large quantity then we
would have like three or four decoy cars
that would be surrounding this
particular car right and wherever it
goes they would block you know if a cop
cane did you ever drive the car that had
the drugs in it of course not that great
guy and in the beginning uh I think I
was only in in the game about three
months before I hired my first person
that started to take all the risks that
that I used to take and it pretty much
moved me almost in a position of M
horrible especially at the time that we
started because you know I didn't know
about conspiracy at first you know I
thought that the only way you could go
to prison for it for drugs as you get
caught with it in your pocket or in a
bag or something like that I didn't know
he go yeah how do you find our
conspiracy how do you trust the guy okay
this guy's gonna drive the drug car and
if he gets pulled over he won't flip he
won't tell on me
well he's probably been
for you know he knows the code I mean we
got plenty of guys in our neighborhood
like that you know Ben Brea all day life
in and out of jail every week you know
and he just can't figure out how to stay
out of prison you know I mean it's
almost like a second home to him so you
get that guy now and you can teach him
how to stay out of prison because not
only do you you teach him the way you
avoided the cops but you also know that
if you get busted he's a stand-up guy
are they making a series about you based
on you we working on it we were working
on the TV we're working on the movie
right now we I'm hoping my man Kush
finishes the script here in the next
couple weeks and we fund it right now
for the movie we had all the money in
the bank I'm working with Reginald
Hudlin and our Kym Hardy for the motion
picture we're also talking with a zach
and a Mona Scott about the TV series I'm
hoping that I get it done here in a
couple weeks
yeah but don't you where they're gonna
take artistic license like you watch
I'll Chapel or one of those like they
always they they kind of create
characters to just tell the story a
little bit easier or they do scenes like
they didn't really happen and you worry
about losing any kind of control and
your life being told the way you don't
want to be told well you know that
that's one of the reason my movie hasn't
already been done because when I went to
the studio's basically what they were
telling me is that they were going to
give me some money and have me to walk
away and and and I think that my story
is too important to to just let somebody
take it and turn it into Hollywood
because I think people can can learn
from my experience and that's why I did
the documentary are you started doc
already yeah I know yeah so yeah so so I
really feel important that I really
think it's important that our young
people get to see a real drug story from
from start to end and I think that it's
gonna be very educational form when when
they get started because not only did I
deal with it from the cellar but you
know I lived with people who used you
know I stayed with him I I wasn't the
guy who who made the money and moved out
of the neighborhood but I actually
stayed in my neighborhood I stayed in
the houses with people who actually used
because I didn't think was nothing wrong
with using I just stopped using them
home oh you're
the drugs alone just for a couple weeks
what were you doing coke coke not crack
or anything like that
I'm cracking coke they all the same how
did you get over it
I just quit you know I woke up one
morning
III started using it I got up to an
ounce of cocaine and at that time I was
considered rich nine like $9,000 and
everybody was like oh man let's have a
big party in and snort up and smoke up
all your coke and I was like all right
let's do it use up all myself but I was
like ah yeah let's have a party and I
celebrate with my friends and we started
putting it in weed and next thing I know
I woke up and I had like three hundred
dollars to my name and I was like you
know what this is not what you got in it
is for today was the last day it's over
and I quit well you what a drug shows
get wrong what a lot of them like what's
something that they do that is just that
they just are missing well you know
first of all they don't they don't want
to it's something about Hollywood man
Hollywood is it's a strange animal right
they love drug dealers stories but they
don't let the drug dealers you know it's
like they don't want us to be on the set
they don't want us to show them what
really took place you know like this
movie that they stole my my cell phone
it's no fault of flake or whatever it's
called John Singleton you know John read
my script he was one of the first people
to buy one of my books and then he comes
out with the show costs no-fault I'm
like what the hell John you know and
then you didn't even call me over and
ask me for it give me a job consultation
or something like did you watch it going
like I know that's lifted I know that I
know exactly we got this I took it took
the knee I couldn't watch it that's a
bow
screw over a freeway Rick Ross yeah it
wasn't and but you know I'm not trying
to go back to prison you know I ran into
him one day - coming down some stairs
how was that for I looked at its pants
it makes you 18 and pee in his pants
because his face showed that all over
Mike oh my god I saw a ghost but do you
ever wish like this there's there's ways
of getting
he's done many years ago that you
probably can't and incorporate anymore
don't you ever wish that you had I wish
I did I was but you know what like I
said before those same skills that I had
my success inside of the drug business
I'm actually seeing them come to
flotation right now in in the jet world
you know I'm having some successes not
not two numbers yet that I had in the
drug business but I feel like I'm finna
touch some of those numbers I feel like
I'm my numbers again where they be crazy
people are becoming aware you know that
I am Alive dand I'm not dead that the
rapper who stole my name is not me so
it's just a matter of time you know and
and you know I'm just keep hitting that
ball you know have you bumped into him
at all or no no he keeps doing
bodyguards with him
you try met the other Rick Ross yeah
yeah okay so um selling a drug you've
done this before haven't you yeah but um
but it's it's not the hardest thing to
sell right the night I think we're oh
I'm in Chris Rock had a joke about how
like the drug sells itself right you
don't really need a market the drug it's
addictive I'm not trying to miss that
but what fat what fascinated me was not
the ability to sell something that
everybody already wants it's the ability
to scale up a business
wallet being illegal for me that seems
like the hardest thing making 900
million dollars while the feds are
watching is way harder than its selling
like cycling classes it's definitely
it's definitely tough when you're
dealing with all those elements and and
that's why when I look at it and I look
at drug dealers you know when I go out
and I talk to these young people about
selling drugs and and the point that you
just made like not only do you have to
beat the cops but you gotta beat your
customer too because you don't know when
the day that this guy who you've been
selling to is gonna put his gun out and
say you know what we're not buying that
[ __ ] no more we're gonna take it today
you know so you got to always deal with
that as well so how do you transition
that into the real world now you're
selling a book right there's ton
people that sell books people aren't
addicted to books how do you translate
that I'm definitely a different dynamic
right so now you got a you got a
transition marketing you probably have
to rely way more on marketing in this
world within where you have to well I'm
Way more on protection and well know you
have to do you have to have marketing in
the other world as well because what
separates one dealer from another dealer
well should I buy from you and not buy
from Jim how'd you get that I do do that
marketing because your service you know
you treat them right you give them a
better price you give them a better
product you know you cater to the
customer you up later you get up early
in the morning I mean the same
principles the same principles that work
with a book if you do a book once you
want you got to have substance in your
book you know if you said in the book
and has no substance nobody's gonna come
back and buy it so if you said in
cocaine and it's really mud nobody's
gonna come back and buy so on that level
that you were are like you know there's
all these fights that guys however
territories and who sells here and who
sells it you guys you didn't have to
really deal with that did you because of
the level you're on I didn't have to
deal with that most guys couldn't match
my price so if it was a guy that that
was competition I would go to him and I
would say okay let's do who got the best
price if your people get you the best
price
I'll buy from you if I got the best
price you buy from me right aren't you
wearing are being killed all the time
not really you don't really have to
worry about that when you were caring
your business a certain way and then you
know the guys that you're talking to
like I didn't just go on the street and
see some kid walking down the street and
be like hey you want to sell cocaine and
it doesn't work like that
it's a clientele just like it's a
clientele for for that shirt you went on
what does that trap trap music have you
been trap music Museum see I opened a
museum in Atlanta that like kind of
shows the history of trap music is that
right yeah yeah yeah so somebody had to
build up a clientele where people want
to go to trap music and see the museum
so it's the same thing
with selling drugs you know when people
come to LA guys from out of town they
looking for Rick Ross did you well I'm
looking for Rick Ross I know I'm gonna
get robbed I normally get what I want
it's guaranteed you know it's the same
thing and anybody that could mess up so
that that's what you're offering right
that's like part of the business plan
and anybody that messes up that part of
the business plan messes up the business
correct so you're protecting those
assets right absolutely and how do you
handle people that mess that up how do
you handle your employees that mess that
up will you just kick them out the
organization and it's in as simple as
that you're not worried about blowback
know what I mean what they gonna do go
to cops until that could happen but you
know in our neighborhood it's it's a
taboo to go to the cops until how about
that there were seven if you catch
somebody stealing I'm sure that happens
sometimes they still all the time part
of the game you know I looked at it like
this he I started with $125 so I'm
always ahead of the game right I'm
always ahead 125 bucks I'm always ahead
of the game I've been ahead of the game
since that started when you very poor
sorry sir that's a really pot like that
the way of looking at it like that that
wouldn't frighten somebody into not
doing it so how do you guarantee that
they don't do it or what's the determine
guarantee that they won't do they're
gonna steal you know this deal I know
right now the people don't steal from me
right now but guess what as long as I
win more than I lose I'm good with it
so that's your philosophy you'll allow a
certain amount of stealing breakers
you're still Nick break it yes it's like
any store well I shouldn't knocks right
right yeah anytime [ __ ] priors are a
couple bikes for a loft uh the Cardoza
built into the business it's built in
right so and you're not worried that
people could go oh we could steal from
this guy yeah not gonna do that they
don't try to you know I don't care who
you they try to chapo I guarantee you
did it and they say he killed people
right but I guarantee you people figure
out how to steal a little something from
me and they did it yeah and someone
party got caught and got the hair cut
off they certain you went to jail the
first time and you got out were you was
there still was your empire
still left for you or had that been
picked through and rummaged through and
it was gone it was gone the only thing I
had left was a couple I think I might
have had one house left and and I had a
theater left which was which was my ace
in the hole
I was really had put my pants on at the
ADA that the ADA was gonna put me in a
position that would've been out of this
world
so was that because you had to spend so
much on legal fees and things like that
or is that because the people that were
around after you were in jail were like
well well just well you know when you
come up selling drugs they tell you to
put all your property and other people
names yeah so I did and then what
happened with those people so when you
go to jail they put in the paper
front-page LA Times Rick Ross's getting
a life sentence without the possibility
of parole
oh he no longer needs it so the property
and sell it and do what they want to do
with the money aunties uncles
I mean cousins everybody's just like and
then it's like I guess it's like
everybody starts to talk to everybody
like I'm keep in mind me too yeah so no
you come home now you gotta kill your
whole family
like where's my stuff do you come back
in 13 years I didn't even ask for it
when I came home I had refocused my mind
on what I had to do and I'm not one who
chases bad money and then you know you
ever heard of throwing good money after
bad money I've learned it and I did that
a few times in the drug Menace you know
like a guy he messes up and he comes
back and he got a great story and you
say alright I'm gonna give you another
chance and you know this is a good guy
he's been good to you before so you
really want this guy to do well but it
just doesn't work out so he [ __ ] up
again he [ __ ] up again
so you don't keep trying to get him back
you know you like cut your losses like
okay this guy he he boss he fell off
something happened to him I don't know
what it is but he's not gonna work out
and that's the way I came home you know
what all the stuff I did in the drug
business was was done and over with I
was gonna take on a new life a new leaf
and put on my focus in there because I
understood that I had never I never gave
myself a chance to run a real business
other than selling drugs the only
business I mean I had motels and junkie
or
president anti shots but when I bought
all that stuff I always put somebody
else in charge I never took it myself
and said you know what I'm gonna run
this and that's why I had never been
successful at a business because I had
never ran in myself and then I looked at
I was saying well I would never give
nobody my whole dope sack right at them
take all that and don't supervise them
and don't say nothing so I said that uh
I want to see now if if I take those
same principles and actually run the
business myself yeah you know that's
interesting because in order to run that
business you have to pay attention to
every single detail because you're
worried about getting arrested getting
robbed when it's an illegal business you
have to worry about everything if you
can take that attention to detail and
put it into a legal business it seems
like you'd be way ahead of the game like
that that's probably the secret that a
lot of failed businesses don't they
don't put that kind of detail into
everything that they do oh no question
and I just you know I'm just excited to
to be able to to do legal business now I
mean I'm like I can't sleep I can't wait
to the day starts you can tell people
when you succeed yeah it's so much it's
so much better and and even now I I've
already slept just since I've been out
you know I'm right now I'm reading books
about the internet how how to use the
internet better mm-hmm
oh yeah that was a huge change from when
I mean you went away in 96 and came out
I think 2009 the internet I mean I only
stayed out for six months I didn't even
I barely got [ __ ] when I was out six
months wait you from went when I got out
in 94 94 I went back in 95 when did you
first go in 89 oh 89 okay that's great
Oh getting it laid the minute you got
out I did but it was like you didn't get
it that's gotta be the awful you finally
get used to life without as much as you
can and this is not and then all of a
sudden you're right back in jail so so
so I really didn't touch the Internet
that's six months and Internet wasn't
even popping he's only 94 yeah
being it really guy loud really I think
they said after after Google really
started popping after the world trace in
it thing is when Google really really
went crazy yeah the people would use it
and the internet was getting like you
would use it for the we would use it for
the radio show but it wasn't every
single aspect of your life it wasn't
like your banking it wasn't everything
you do there was still rejecting I
remember being in college and when
Facebook came out yeah of course
remember you needed like a college email
to get on it and I think we all reject
it initially really guys as corny well I
was just putting on pictures I took
forever to upload everything yeah it was
stupid yeah now we're obsessed with it
so when you go in in 95 and that's when
it's life without the possibility of
parole
correct do you sit there going oh my god
that last six months was literally my
last six months of freedom this is what
its gonna be or did you and I felt like
that at time you did yeah I did it was
like especially when I first when I
first did the first day matter of fact
when the cops when I thought it was cops
that it was a setup it was like oh
because you go so you get out of you you
go to jail for selling drugs you get out
of jail for the six months and the story
that I've heard is that somebody was
looking to have you introduced them to
somebody else that's what it was it was
an introduction but it was what they got
me with is uh what they call aiding in a
bid brokering they say I was the
brighter in the deal it was like that
scene in blow where George Jung is
looking around like oh no no same
scenario I had this theater that I
bought right before I went to prison and
my goal was to make this theater like
the West Coast Apollo you know where
like all the new artists would come when
they come to LA they would come on this
stage and and I needed some dollars that
the finish it so most suppliers started
calling me saying hey why are you asking
everybody for money you can get your own
money and over the six months he got
into my head and and uh and I decided
that I would make the introduction you
know and all hell broke it was just that
the whole thing was a setup it was a
setup from the supplier from the
beginning was working with the cops
trying to get you to that Oscar Danilo
Blandon
yeah Wow so they're like we want this
there was something after you got it out
of jail they said no no we want we want
him we want him locked up for it yeah
for some reason well you know le times
he did a big big article on me and day
one had did an article about my release
from prison so I guess that made me
attractive to him
sure for whatever reason I was when
things started being public it wasn't so
quiet anymore right now it's like now we
can't have him around did you miss the
anonymity the nice quiet days of riding
around in the coroner's car nobody
looking at you I mean you miss the days
of just blending in being able to drive
around with a trunk full of coke you get
away with a certain amount of stuff as
long as you're like humble well you know
what the feds does they have a list
right like if you go in one of the
offices right now they got a list on the
wall uh-huh and they got all the guys
one two three four five all the way
maybe like 50 50 guys that they want but
they'll take any one of those guys in
between if they can get them right you
know like we really want him but we know
he's might be a little tougher to get so
we'll take number two number three and
and just with this workday we're on it
seems like that doesn't it like oh yeah
like guys who get like even with Takashi
right you know the your whatever saying
it seems like it seems like the the feds
almost stepped in were like listen
you're not gonna go around like wreaking
havoc and acting like you're invincible
so you can make yourself go up on that
list sure exactly right your crime and
then sing about it attractive like you
could be number 20 on that list but you
might make yourself become number two
and once you're number two it's say okay
we got to put some way we can get you to
like we've been known we could've been
got you right we've been knowing that
that you've been slipping but the little
crimes you've been committing is not as
serious as these other guys up here well
now you just put yourself in a position
to where now you're more attractive
what's your what your your game was
always doing the work that would put you
at number one but keeping yourself right
around number 20 so they were like
ignoring right that's the whole idea
with the Mafia right yeah calling it
like Cosa Nostra is like didn't even
have a name
for it right once you establish a name
for something it's like okay we know
what it is we can take you down ones
just like oh we're just a bunch of guys
we don't have any organization well you
can't flaunt it like you look at Martin
shkreli van or scrum have you say his
name course he you know they let him out
on bail but he was such a prick about it
he was taunting the judge and he wanted
a piece of Hillary Clinton's hair the
only [ __ ] you back in yeah like you
can't tell the federal government to go
[ __ ] themselves when they're looking at
you Superboy Roger stone was coming on
this radio showing getting himself
knocked up the list every line every
every time calling in and just knocking
himself up the list that Wow I have a
feeling he will skate though Rogers a
smart guys been there since Nixon you
don't survive since Nixon in that world
nice number to long Russia's a pretty
smart guy he ended up with life without
the possibility of parole
that's a good point if somebody sit
across it enough so your first day your
second time in jail the first day and
you have life without the possibility of
parole are you looking around going this
is it works there for the rest of my
life this wasn't my life yeah I mean
what the things I had to think about
like how am I called my daughter's I had
I had a daughter at that time she was
about seven years old and I had promised
her I mean she wrote me like once a week
I don't a few people who wrote me she
did write me and uh she was like that
don't go back don't go back and now I
promised I wasn't going back and now
here I am back and you know she's used
to me picking her from school and you
know just doing this stuff together and
now her mom is like she's asking about
you every day so it was like the worst
feeling you know to lie not only to
yourself and and adults but now I've
also lied to my babies who who were just
so happy that I got home and and now was
going only six months and I'm back so it
was like just the worst feeling that you
could feel did you keep in touch with
her the whole time did she stay in
contact with you while you were in jail
she did after after I couldn't I
couldn't face her for six months first
six months in prison I couldn't talk to
it was like you know how can you tell a
seven-year-old kid that her dad is never
coming back again you know or it's a
possibility I might never come back so
it took me it took me a while to come to
grips enough to face her in an apology
eyes to her and let her know that I
totally did you keep hope alive cuz you
just said there's a possibility of never
coming back but literally in the
sentence it says there isn't without the
possibility you are not coming back yeah
Rick they were moved out I don't know
you read the LA Times article when Jesse
cats coming to interview me for LA
magazine uh-huh and that's after I'd
learn how to read my reading was good
well and and I discovered the issue that
that I knew was gonna be friendly from
prison so so even and even after that
you still have those days where it's up
and down you know like because you're
still depending on three judges to to to
make a ruling right well how did you how
did you end up what did you find that
allowed you to get out oh it was the
lowest three words it was called
continuous criminal spree a continuous
criminal spree is where somebody is out
committing crime and they've never been
brought to justice
mm-hmm what they charged me with into
three strikes and in order to be a three
striker you have to go to prison
if you have to commit a crime and go to
prison and get out they didn't get out
and commit another crime go to prison
and get out again and then if you come
in at third crimes in your three Stryker
that's the third well well mine was a
continuous criminal spree even though I
was just I was selling drugs in
different states I had never been
brought to justice you know nobody had
ever thought me and spanked my hand and
say hey you're bad man without office
yeah
so they knocked it down to twenty years
I guess because it was there's only two
strikes see it was only two strikes Wow
yeah that was really and what was it
like when you find that it has to be
like alright this there's no way this is
so good to be truly real and then I jump
on the phone and call my lawyer and I
say man I found I finally found he bust
my bubble so it don't apply to you from
different states if it happened on in
California you'd be good because the law
writ was like from from city to city you
know like if you got caught in LA
and then you went to hangar wood and you
got caught then those would be
considered the same but mine he said was
different because I was crossing state
lines but I was like no the federal
government is all over the country so
they don't go but I say zero not only
did he not find it when you found it he
didn't know that you had yes for money
back that's got to be frustrating when
you find it in like your life you wonder
why the [ __ ] didn't the lawyer fight
know what am I paying you well you know
and that that was another another lesson
that I learned from that you know like
guys used to tell me when I was in jail
before I started doing my own case they
was like you depend on a lawyer to do
your case yeah serious is your case is
and what they made me understand is that
you should never depend on somebody else
to do for you what you should be doing
for yourself if it's important to you
because they was like well he got a wife
he's gonna go home and be with his wife
where you gonna be at write in my cell
he gonna be with his kids where you
gonna be at you're not his only client
right as other clients and the fact that
the case is done anyway he already in
jail down at sale yeah what's he gonna
do spend an hour a week oh my god no
nothing he's probably not even there
right what they made me understand is
that I should be fighting my case the
same way I sew drugs and that's what I
did I started reading 18 19 hours a day
you're treating legal books yeah so to
bring legal books Wow yeah I don't know
how many legal books I read I mean I
read over 300 business books about doing
drugs any game I go into I mean there's
no business that that that I don't feel
I'm gonna punish the business world you
know the business world for I see some
stuff that uh you know I'm getting ready
start throwing my weight around if you
were to sell drugs now how would you do
it I thought about that but it is the
same principle I mean you you you want
to treat people the way that you want to
be treated
yeah you want to make everybody feel
special and when you do that they have a
tendency just to
cater to you you know if you give
somebody something it's like when I was
in jail and I was at at what they call a
new Rock Lompoc
a USP and in Rock City they had me in
the middle of the hallway I had to do my
job was right in front of captain's
office it was about 10 to 15 of us in
our job we had to mop the floors the
floor about 40 feet long both ways and
our job was to mop the floor ten over so
you know we was mop this floor a
thousand times a day but they really
wanted us right next to the captain's
office so he could keep our eye on us
and we had to have red tags and so forth
and what I did is I noticed that
everybody came past us you know you had
to pass the captain's office going to
the yard and so what I did is I just
started something simple as just saying
hi to everybody
and some of the meanest toughest racist
guys what I notice is when they would
walk by they started beating me to
saying hi like hey what a Rick before I
could say what up to them they started
sending it to me it was just like a
little game I started playing so so one
of the things that I found out is that
whatever you give to people they have a
tendency to give it back to you just a
friendly interaction for people who are
not used to getting a lot of friendly
interaction exactly and it changed the
whole world and these guys became almost
like a lie to me like they they
genuinely liked me just because you know
everybody likes to hit an ankle yeah if
you just yeah I guess so yeah definitely
yeah yeah cheers you mopping and a guy
walking by that's really I guess that's
a smart psychology though yeah to use as
a guys coming by just to say hello I'm
sure there were some guys that didn't
respond to no I don't I don't remember
anybody well did I mean even if a guy
didn't I still would do it anyway if you
evidentially and eventually you break
him down you know it's it's just we'll
you know this is just playing wheel so
if you use those same principles and
then the other thing that I found out
that if somebody likes you you're not
gonna see you do bad they're gonna make
sure that you are right you know just
like if you had a friend and and and you
saw that he was trying his best but you
know for some reason he just can't get
it going
yes you gonna help him so when you're
when
you're I mean whatever business you're
in you're in the business of being liked
right your hands is that's the first
that's the first - so how do you how do
you deal now and you're getting into
legal business of the people who are
coming up to you going like you flooded
communities with drugs you kill people
or your family that much and you don't
they don't because they'll say it out to
your face I have got it you know
audience who know somebody stand up as a
my mother
od don't on cocaine your cocaine and I
was like what you have to acknowledge it
- like yeah I mean I was selling drugs
and people do stupid right right is it
part of the American dream to sell drugs
absolutely you see these like a really
wealthy prominent American families that
made their bones essentially either in
the drug or alcohol game right
absolutely I mean the Kennedys right
well sure running bootleg Joe Kennedy
Yahoo Lake right so do do you think like
a hundred years from now we'll look back
at the Rick Ross's and see anybody ever
thought marijuana will be legal in
America true I mean you could walk down
the street in LA right now and smoke
marijuana and they sell it on every
corner
you know it's like when I got home from
prison and I saw that I was like what
you know like every corner in LA they
got a marijuana shop yeah there are
every single other medical you know you
can go to the club absolutely and smoke
but I mean I also think that it depends
on how the story is told in more and
more the stories are being told honestly
- how people feel like nobody's mad at
Pablo Escobar like their watch nobody's
watching except for families of the
victims families of the victims but when
you watch those shows people aren't
getting mad they're going they go
especially the beginning oh that's so
cool exactly and there and there I think
that that we are entering this space
where you're Rick Ross gonna be in a
pretty good position because people are
open to the idea of applying the
business
and of things into stuff pert it isn't
drugs right hundred because there isn't
I mean and we try to let these people
think for us right and letting these
people in Washington sit down and they
think of us and they haven't even walked
the street in 50 years you know they
haven't walked down
none of the boulevards in in no city you
know they just sit back in a big desk
and smoke cigars and and make decisions
for everybody and then we are here we
sensible you know we got enough sense I
gotta tell people then we have enough
sense that our kids are not running
around taking rat poison why we got to
figure out why kids don't take rat
poison why they won't take rats
rat poison then we can figure out how to
get him off drugs there's a reason the
reason I wore this sweatshirt I knew you
were gonna be here and you didn't think
you were cool I was really impressed
that yeah I took control of how his
story was told when you make a museum
don't set the timeline for trap music or
whatever it is what is trap music I've
never heard the term music about the
essentially about the drug trade and all
they specifically tour it to Atlanta was
he a drug dealer yeah maybe but but
essentially I walk into the museum and
then the timeline starts with ti now who
knows if he was the guy who started trap
music but he put the flag down like who
knows who got to the moon first but if
you go to the moon there's a [ __ ]
American flag on the moon and it shows
you the importance of setting that I
think we definitely got there first yeah
we definitely like for you the
storytelling is crucial absolutely
because right now people are like oh
that's the other Rick Ross absolutely
absolutely and if you retell the story
it's like oh that guy in Miami
no that's the especially because the one
of Miami has been calling himself the
boss for so long these going to be
you first played the boss I know he was
your CEO well he got in trouble Rick
Ross the rapper got in trouble for I
guess mentioning guys names that he
shouldn't have mentioned oh yes I did
get in trouble for that
Harry Hoover yeah and the other guy do
you know those guys yeah yeah I know I I
don't know Larry personally I know meets
from from the telephone he came after I
was already in prison but uh annoying so
they like getting mentioned in songs by
the other Rick Ross well you know what
without without permission right it's
kind of disrespectful right I mean even
what he did to me is disrespectful you
don't see it as a somebody maintaining
your legacy like you don't see it as
somebody who's like I admire Rick Ross
so much I'm gonna name myself well well
you know it's a certain way to do that I
see the compensation element your record
label is named after Maybach give me
some of the drive around corrections
officer bother you too like that does
that removal really bother me it don't
bother me really that dude it was just
it was just you know it's a ways you
know Chad it should have been handled
you know and because I know the guy
loves me to death he probably loves me
bigger than anybody else in this country
because he's the first person I ever see
to have my name tattooed on his hands
you do that to somebody that means a lot
you know most people only tattoo they
did home he's on it on it on anybody
right so he tattooed a party I spoke
from one time in jail but I haven't
spoke to him since then no was it a
friendly communication or no well you
know I thought it was I thought we were
going somewhere you know I talked about
coming down where we could talk about
doing some business together because I
already wanted to do business with him
you know my first thing is business you
know so okay yeah he disrespect you by
using a name but how can you make some
money with him that's what I was
thinking and then one of these I can't
associate myself
ex-criminal business person well there
was a bunch of video I was obsessed with
those video like I think the gangsters
have put all these videos out where they
were they were kind of taunting Rick
Ross Gangster Disciples yeah Oh video
what's that
they all went to deal all those guys
knew it he did right well you know what
you put out in federal crimes but put
out videos online and it brings you up
the list this is we're not sure but I
think he cancelled the tour he did it
was the first time that in this country
that uh a major artist had to cancel a
tour behind threats behind threats yeah
well is there anything he could do that
would make you happy at this point I
mean you know I'm still wide open to uh
to work with him I don't have anybody
that that I wouldn't work with you know
as long as it makes sense I just like to
stay busy man just keep keep working
keep pushing keep driving and I would
definitely sit down with him if he
wanted to sit down and talk about how we
could uh how we can move forward but you
I sued him you know and it cost like a
million and a half that I old I hold him
and his record label million 1/2 of
attorney fees right now one he well how
did he win attorneys you want a bunch I
know he wanted I don't know how he want
to tarnish I couldn't understand how
they want either but basically what the
judge said is that I should have filed a
lawsuit a year I mean out of here five
days before I got out of prison you get
you get statue limitation that's two
years and the way she calculated the
time I was five days short of filing my
lawsuit so she filed a lawsuit
immediately when you got out of prison
yeah yeah I did so the way it works is
whoever loses has to pay the other ones
attorney fees right I like that rule
though cuz then you don't have people
just suing for no reason yeah but is he
gonna make you is he gonna make you
honor that no no they haven't they
haven't they haven't put on my oh my oh
my credit work that out of the key ones
well that'll be a nice fix you know what
I mean if they walk away from that that
would be a fair fix like if they they
don't ask you for that yeah I don't want
if they don't ask me for
we go with business I think a lot of
people get caught up in ego right
they're like this person is
disrespecting me and you know we are
wipe them off the face of the earth and
you're like now if you can still bring
me money then we can still do absolutely
I feel totally that way some people do
let egotistical OTT of mistakes but not
on purpose you know men you're doing
something and it goes wrong believe I
made a mistake
not that I purposely planned on
sabotaging whatever it was because
that's not it's not my objective since
you thought you were gonna at one point
die in prison and then you get out he's
kind of like do you enjoy things that
you wouldn't have enjoyed at one oh
absolutely you you have you you you get
a whole new appreciation of just life
and and being free you know you figure
for four full you know twenty years you
can't touch a woman you know you can't
eat certain foods you can't go places
you can't where you get to fly an
airplane when when they fly you on Con
Air but other than that you don't get to
fly on airplanes I mean it's just so
much stuff that you miss out on and and
now with me being in the position that I
am I'm getting to do things now that I
so drugs to do you know like I used to
sell drugs to go to a party in and be
the life of the party you know you want
to be the life of the party so you sell
drugs to get in that position and now
I'm getting those same opportunities
without you know selling the drugs how
how difficult of the time would add a
Jim Norton let's say Jim Norton doesn't
have comedy to fall back on he can't
entertain people with his jokes if Jim
Norton like this but he's Easy's no
personality goes into the federal prison
is he really gonna be the guy who gets
passed around they're gonna try to pass
me around and I tell them if they do
that I'll tell the guard
[Laughter]
Jim with Jen would it would be tough
foot foot and in other races is really
tougher than than black being black is
is is it's kind of almost like a freedom
card you know because they don't have
the same grooves you know that that a
lot of other people do but like white
gangs are really tough on their own you
know like if you can I see like it was a
guy named Tom McCormack he came in and
you know me and I've got to be really
cool and they told Todd if he couldn't
be hanging with me so much you know like
everywhere we go because he was reading
and we both doing business and we
studying and and you know we just kicked
it you know I'm saying and they wanted
to beat him up because uh the first day
dealing with me oh I become kind of like
his protector but the day that I left
and he didn't come when I got back to
the cell they had two guys that came in
with locks and socks and had beat him
pretty bad and how now you you you would
protect him how he cuz you're not a big
guy so he would protect him through
reputation or through that work if he if
they do something to him while he's with
me then I might get in it you know and
then it's a problem and then it's a
problem when it becomes a black problem
and not now with the blacks be like why
are you hanging out with this white guy
no they would never say that would they
now just because like I said didn't like
you would still side with you in that
situation
absolutely absolutely cuz that's
survival at that point right it becomes
a race thing you know like when it's a
race thing an NGO order the white guys
like if the black and the whites get
into a scuffle even if you like a
Christian to something then you stay out
of the way you know you don't even come
out your sale you know if you a white
Christian and you stand your sale does
that happen what guys to have to fight
guys they like like the blacks and the
whites are fighting and you know you're
friends with certain white guys alone so
what do you guys do just trying to take
it easy on each other like that
situation I didn't fight while I was
there I don't have not one fight the
whole time I was in
that's rare right well you know I was
smart enough to stay in any areas you
know they don't fight in a law library
they don't know no why is that because
they don't wanna get banned from the
library there's a reason it's not an
action-packed place I would imagine a
library well according to the wire I
mean a D'Angelo Barksdale was killed in
the library oh I didn't I didn't realize
the cementery the wire that's true
wasn't it was good shoking much of a
fight